This program is being presented to you
by the Heraeus International Winter
School on gravity and light.
So, good morning and welcome to the
International Winter School on gravity
and light here at the Johannes Kepler
University in Linz.
Um, we're now joined by 50 participants
from all over the world for the
remainder of the school, for the actual
physical part. And we'll start with
lecture 13, where the first 12 lectures
dealt with the mathematical foundations
of general relativity, and now the
character of the course will change. We
will now employ the mathematical tools
we've introduced in order to describe
relativistic space-time and general
relativity. So, um
that means now we need to argue about
why we choose which structure and
these are rather vague arguments because
it's about physics and physics is more
complicated than mathematics.
Because mathematics everything is clear.
It's just self-referential
and that is exactly its power, that it
mathematics per se has nothing to do to
do with the world and it wants nothing
to do with the world and exactly that
it's it's is its power. Now, in physics
that's a more dirty subject because you
need to relate your notions to the world
and at the end you need to make
predictions. So, um a lot more hand
waving and a lot more arguing is
required.
Having said that, of course we want to
reduce that to a minimum. We
nevertheless we still want to develop a
as consistent a set of notions as
possible in order to meaningfully talk
about what we are talking.
And of course the picture we're going to
present may need revision one day. Maybe
we already do have the experiments that
require that we revise the theory and
nobody at the moment knows how deep this
revision will go.
But of course in order to surgically
change the theory somewhere, you need to
understand the old theory, the current
the standard theory currently everybody
is working with. So, this is the theory
we're presenting here and only towards
the end of the school I will go into
some more detail about how this theory
might be changed and if you go about
that, how this might be done.
So, the topic today is relativistic
space-time and if you recall
from lecture nine
the definition of Newtonian space-time
that we had a set
equipped with a topology such that it
was a four-dimensional manifold we
equipped it with a smooth structure
and a torsion-free connection
and additionally a so-called absolute
time and this absolute time was a smooth
function on the four manifold and there
were two compatibility conditions. No,
there was one definition on uh having
really a time slices, that is that the
gradient of this absolute time function
nowhere vanish and the second condition
was that time flow uniformly, that was
that nabla dt was zero. Um
if you recall this definition of
Newtonian space-time and at the same
time
the definition I gave you at the
beginning of this lecture course in
lecture one and the definition
of relativistic space-time
I gave in lecture one, so actually
before lecture one
which at the time
may have been quite incomprehensible,
but now it no longer is and I no longer
write down the words because we now know
better, we can write down this is a
manifold a topological manifold of four
dimensions,
we find a smooth atlas for it
and back then we said it's equipped with
a torsion-free connection. Excellent.
Torsion-free.
So far it seems the same, but then for a
manifold
space-time manifold a relativistic one,
we have two more structures. So, here we
had this absolute time and here we have
two more structures. What are they? They
are a Lorentzian metric
on the manifold.
Lorentzian metric and I remind you we
had the signature convention plus minus
minus minus.
And the T here
is a so-called time orientation
and I'll tell you in a second what that
is technically.
So, but what I want you to observe is
that what the role played in Newtonian
space-time by the absolute time function
is now played by the interplay of two
additional structures or two different
structures, a Lorentzian metric and a
time orientation.
So, first time orientation.
What is that?
Because all the other notions appearing
in here and in fact appearing in this
longish definition I provided at the
beginning of the lecture course in
lecture one
um
all the remaining concepts here are
already clarified. You know what a
Lorentzian metric is, a connection and
so on.
So, what's a time orientation?
Definition.
Let M O
A
G, we don't need to talk about the
connection yet, we just look at this, a
Lorentzian manifold.
And probably we want an oriented atlas.
So,
we take an oriented atlas.
Later on we need that. Let this be a
Lorentzian manifold.
Then a time
orientation
is given
by a
vector field
T, okay? So, we're relieved this is
nothing more complicated than a tensor a
vector field this T. By vector field T
uh that
A
does not vanish anywhere.
So, it's a nowhere vanishing tensor
field.
And that second has the following
property that if you
calculate G of TT at any point in
space-time, the result is always
positive.
So, um let me draw pictures here. Let's
go back to Newtonian space-time first
and then to relativistic space-time.
Yes. It does
not vanish. Pardon me? In the
first one
Oh, does not. Yeah, yeah, I missed it.
Thank you very much.
It does not
vanish. Otherwise it's rather pointless.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you very much.
So, um
let's look at the situation. So, let's
go back to Newtonian space-time.
In Newtonian space-time you go to a
particular point say this one.
This is the four-dimensional space-time
manifold in Newtonian physics
and at this point
the
absolute time function has a certain
value, right? So, if I
have the absolute time function yellow
here
it has a certain value and because it's
smooth, it will have the same value
elsewhere.
Um, I'm just drawing a one plus one
two-dimensional picture of Newtonian
space-time, okay? So, um
this would probably in a
three-dimensional picture which is still
one dimension
too little would more look like this and
this point lies in here and this is
where T is constant, okay? But I even go
down a further dimension and look at it
like this, okay? In order to draw
diagrams. So, I reduce the picture by
two dimensions. So, this is the this is
this and now you know that the gradient
of the dt
it's a covector, it's not a vector. So,
one is tempted to say this is the
gradient, well at least if
the next level line, so say this was T
equals one, this if this goes like this
then you would say this is the direction
of the gradient, but we know that the
gradient is a covector. In fact, the
gradient is best understood as
this little
plane attached to here okay?
And what
this allows you is the definition of a
future directed vector. So, we recall
a vector X in Newtonian space-time
was called
future pointing or future directed
if
the T of X is greater than zero.
Which meant that any direction
that was up here
anything here
any vector in this half space
and this is a picture in the tangent
space, right? So you have a point here
and this little plane here
uh this already lies in the cotangent
space, an element of the cotangent
space, and these this shaded area is
that subset
of the tangent space at this point. So
let me say this is a subset
of the tangent space at this point where
all the vectors lie that are future
directed. Okay?
And the ones that lie on here, they are
annihilated by DT.
That's the standard theorem. And the
ones that point backwards, they have a
negative sign under DT.
Okay? So these are the future directions
where you can go.
Okay.
Now, if you draw the same picture down
here
what you get is the following.
First of all, you start from a point.
And now the first thing is you do not
have an absolute time function.
You just don't have it.
What you have instead is a Lorentzian
metric. The Lorentzian metric provides
in each tangent space, so if I again
draw now a picture in the tangent space
at that point the metric, the Lorentzian
metric you know
gives you a structure like this
in a tangent space.
We did this also in the tutorials, I
think. Okay? This is what Lorentzian
metric gives you.
And um
we now would like to have a sim- similar
definition uh because these future
directed vectors were important because
we said particles are always world have
world lines in Newtonian space-time
whose tangents are future directed.
Okay?
We're now going to talk about future
directed particle world lines, but we
would like
to restrict
to particle world lines whose tangent
vectors lie inside
this cone
or possibly on its boundary.
But they shouldn't run backwards
and they shouldn't lie outside.
The motivation will be to go from here
to here
that we want to implement the idea that
no massive particle can overtake light.
Okay?
Here
you have future
pointing tangent vectors, future
pointing velocities, which can be arbit-
which can have arbitrarily, well in
quotation mark, high velocity. You know
velocity is a vector. What's a high
velocity if we haven't a metric yet?
Let's not talk about this, but that's
the intuition. And so here we're
interested in distinguishing
one half of this double cone. So all the
vectors that lie in, of course it
continues, right?
But the second half we're not interested
in.
We really just want half a cone, not a
double cone.
For the same reasons we up here in
Newtonian mechanics only want a half
space.
So we want to get rid of this guy.
So how do we do that?
Well
we have here the metric and this time
orientation. And if you look at this
you
have a metric at every point of the
manifold
you have a metric and hence uh in every
tangent space at every point, so also at
another point Q
you may have another cone.
Okay? And how dare I write only
the half cone because what what about
this half I just
eliminated. So these are pictures in
different tangent spaces.
This is a picture in TQM. Okay? So the
cones live in the tangent spaces. They
don't live in the manifold. They live in
the tangent spaces. Well, the point is
of course this vector field T I
introduced over here, this time
orientation
first of all, the G gives you a double
cone. But then if you have a vector
field with that property, say a vector
that's inside the cone here and here
it's inside the cone there, and if you
emphasize that it is a smooth vector
field
then it's clear you wouldn't all of a
sudden flip from here to the opposite
cone, but this would be smoothly chosen.
Okay?
So the combination of a Lorentzian
metric
and a time orientation
gives you a distribution of cones over
all the tangent spaces
in your space-time.
As much as in Newtonian mechanics the
absolute time gives you a distribution
of half spaces
of the tangent space everywhere along
the space-time manifold.
Okay?
Now, in Newtonian theory we could always
introduce a stratified atlases on so
that it always looks like
you have the um
equal time function like this and then
from wherever you are
now again a picture in tangent space,
these are the future directions, right?
Um here gene- generically it won't be
possible to find an atlas such that
cones all stand upright.
But anyway, the cone standing upright or
not uh is a
artifact of the chart you chose. Okay?
Okay, anyway. So um
this is the basic idea. Um
I tried to convey the motivation
to change an absolute time function to
this combined structure. But I will now
make this more precise.
So um
in particular, let me emphasize I did
not argue that in Newtonian mechanics
you have a metric in three space and now
we have a metric in four space.
Well, that's all true. You can also
introduce here a metric if you wish at
some stage in inertial systems and so
on. But the first and foremost task of
the Lorentzian metric is not to measure
any length. The first and foremost task
is to produce these cones.
Okay?
Good. So that's the um that's the time
orientation. Um
this definition
of
relativistic space-time and from now on
I will only refer to it as space-time
and I will only say Newtonian space-time
if we talk about the non-relativistic
version. Yes?
I understand that from the cones
uh we need a metric G
if when
velocity vector the
sign basically
but I still I don't see the
uh
so this is the how the T comes in there.
Okay. Okay. Um
so um
Okay, so the question was
uh what what exactly is the role of the
T? Well, if I just provide you with a
manifold
with a Lorentzian metric here
then you go to an arbitrary point of the
manifold and in the tangent space at
that point
you get the following structure
of vectors where the vectors lying on
here satisfy GXX
= 0 and the vectors in here satisfy GXX
> 0, but also the vectors in down here
satisfy GXX > 0 and all the vectors
lying outside here satisfy GXX
< 0.
So by
requiring that a vector have positive
sign if this is my sign convention, I
select the interior
of this upper cone and the interior of
the lower cone.
However, in order to now make a particle
definition which I'm going to make I
want to talk about future and past.
I want particles to run forward rather
than backward. So I need to eliminate
one of these cones.
But the metric doesn't distinguish
between them, so I need an extra choice
of a vector field that lies either
inside here or inside here.
So I choose the T and say the T is this
one then this chooses this part of the
cone. That's enough information to say
which part I mean and I can eliminate
that one.
And then I get a space-time picture, an
objective space-time picture where each
tangent space of the space-time
there lives a half cone.
That's that's the role of the team.
So, um this definition of space-time
uh
has been
made
to enable
the following
um physical postulates.
Well, rather enable us to stipulate
the following physical postulates.
And um so, that's the first physical
postulate.
One,
the world line
gamma
of a massive particle
um satisfies
by this postulate two conditions.
First,
it lies inside the cone. So, the
velocity Sorry, the the tangent to it
at every point along the curve
lies inside either the forward or the
backward double cone. But, what is the
forward and the backward double cone?
Second condition,
uh gamma at g gamma of lambda
t  v gamma gamma of lambda
is also greater than zero.
So, the picture for this is you have a
trajectory in space-time.
In M, a smooth curve in M.
And now, what you need to check is
whether at every point of the curve, say
at this point,
it is true or it's not true that the
cone that lives at that point anyway.
Okay? You need to look How does the cone
look like? Well, you need to look at the
tangent vector to this curve.
I draw it like this, although I
shouldn't. It's a directional
derivative. You need So, we're starting
to do a tangent space picture, right?
So, let me be precise here. And as soon
as I start drawing this, I'm talking
here about elements all of a sudden in
the tangent space, whereas of course,
the curve was running in the manifold.
That this tangent vector here lies
inside the cone
that we have at this point.
So, the cone, however, is given a priori
because I know the space-time.
And I know it's one of the two cones,
whether it lies in the cone in which
also the t lies, because then the inner
product of these two with respect to
this metric will be positive. If the t
had selected a the
this cone, then the inner product of
this velocity with this t under the
Lorenzi metric would be negative.
Okay? So, in this sense, this t is used
all the time. And so, you check, okay,
at this one point, the tangent vector
lies inside the local cone.
You need to check whether at the next
point
I just draw yet another one here,
whether this tangent vector still lies
within the cone.
But, the cone at that point.
Right?
So, it's very important that space-time
consists
of a half cone in each tangent space.
Which half cones? Well, the ones that
the metric the Lorenzi tensor field
tells you you have.
Yes.
Okay.
It's not an inner product in the sense
that it's a positive definite inner
product, because this has the wrong
signature. If this had
positive signature throughout, it would
induce an inner product on each tangent
space.
Now, this induces a pseudo inner product
on each tangent space. It shares all the
properties, but it doesn't have the
positivity.
And in certain directions, it satisfies
an inverse triangular equality rather
than a triangular
equality. We'll come to that. Okay?
So, if I say inner product, I mean here
Lorenzi inner product or pseudo inner
product.
Okay. So, this is for massive particles.
And the postulate p2 refers to massless
particles.
The world line
world lines of massless
particles
And note that in Newtonian mechanics, we
couldn't talk about massless particles.
In Newtonian mechanics, every particle
has mass. F equals MA, right? You have
to have a non-vanishing mass. It's in
relativity that you can have massless
particles. So, world lines of massless
particles satisfy
a
one
uh that their velocity along the curve
at every point. So, this is at every
point along the curve, of course, at
every point
along the curve,
that the velocity
at every point along the curve
is equal to zero.
That means the tangent vector lies on
the boundary of the cone. But, the
second condition is again
formally the same. This is v gamma gamma
of lambda
v gamma gamma of lambda
We I'm sorry, with the t,
it must have positive
um well, pseudo inner product at each
point. Okay?
Okay. So, uh the picture for this is
I now go the other way around. It's also
maybe more logical. So, say your So,
picture
overall.
Say you have a you have a Lorenzi
space-time.
And I'm now trying to draw the objective
space-time, whatever that means. So, at
every point,
I have a little half cone.
Why would it not look like this? It
could, right? Why not?
Okay.
Now, um
This is the trajectory, the world line.
Sorry, the world line of a massive
particle.
Perfect. Yeah?
I want to ask uh the second condition in
the p1. Yes.
And this tells us uh that we choose the
cone where the vector lies within the
Mhm. But, how do we know that it is
that's the future cone or the past cone?
Because the t says so.
No, it's a very good question. It's a
very good question.
We need to decide what is future and
past, and we need to divide it.
Relatives relativists came up with no
better idea than to say, "Choose it."
However, because the t is a smooth
vector field,
once you start choosing it at some
point, it's more or less determined
how it works in the other points.
Otherwise, you just exchange the notion
of future and past.
Okay? Um the question of what the arrow
of time is, whether time runs like this
or like that, you can have um answers to
this from statistical physics.
And you can have other ideas.
In general relativity, this is no
further resolved. We say, "This is what
it is. We have such a time orientation."
It's different from the oriented atlas,
right? It's a time orientation. It's a
choice of a half cone.
Okay? But, the smoothness makes this
less arbitrary that it than it may seem.
Okay?
Yes.
Yes. The sphere also cannot carry a
Lorenzi metric.
So,
every smooth manifold can carry a
Riemannian metric, but not every smooth
manifold can carry a Lorenzi metric.
So, there are obstruction theorems that
tell you those smooth manifolds can and
those can't.
The same is true with time orientation.
Okay? And uh we'll come to further
constraints. So, by requiring that these
structures exist, there is no guarantee
that for any underlying choice, you can
always put such a structure on top and
it exists. But then the underlying
choices also exclude as a space-time
manifold. So, for instance,
we could think of a two-dimensional
world and say, "Oh, it would be funny if
the two the sphere is orientable, if we
took the S2 the oriented S2 as a smooth
manifold and considered this a
space-time. So, we just need to find a
metric and a
time orientation." Well, the point is
you find don't find a Lorentzian metric.
So, the S2 as an underlying smooth
manifold
can never be made into a space-time.
Okay? So, in this sense, there are
constraints that come by adding further
structures. Can you really add them?
Okay.
Yes.
And so, you you can enter the business
of deriving
uh theorems on on what can
then still survive at the lower level
and what not. And of course, all of that
exists, right?
Okay.
So, here we have a massless particle,
but I should also show you a um
a massive one uh um um No, we have a
massive particle. I'll now show you a
massless particle. Um
Well, a massless one would be this one
here.
Okay. We need a few more cones.
Well, it's clear. Now, I mean, this is
just a repre- representation of all the
possible cones. It could also start
looking like this, right? Why not?
Okay?
So, that means space-time is really this
this collection of cones essentially. In
fact, 9/10 of a metric are determined by
the cones.
You can think about that, right? So, um
claim
9/10
of a metric
are determined
by
their
uh
by the cone.
And only 1/10 then still needs to be
fixed and okay?
9/10. So, if I say the space-time is
essentially distribution of cones,
it's almost right. Only 10% error.
Good.
So, we have this.
Aha. So, well, this uh these are just
postulates, but you see, these
definitions and this motivation has a
lot to do with these postulates, right?
We do this in order to be able to talk
about particles of one kind or of the
other.
However,
all the difficulties one might have at
first with relativity
is that somehow in your head,
you still have this absolute time
function somewhere.
And you still can't wrap your head
around it that the structure of your
tangent spaces that your tangent spaces
at every point are now not divided in
one half space and another half space,
but that they're divided in
one cone
and not that one cone.
Okay?
That's all the problems with the
relativity. There are no others. If we
follow the definitions we're now going
to make,
no such problem will arise. And of
course, in a sense, if you think that
this one half cone opens up more and
more and more, let's say it does that
somehow, don't we get a picture like
this?
Well, yes, right?
So, a cone
is an uh an object from linear algebra.
It's a generalization of vector
subspace.
A cone is a space where the sum of two
vectors that's in there is again in
there,
like a vector subspace,
and where positive
mul- multiples of a vector are again in
there.
That is a stronger requirement than that
any multiple of a vector is again in
there. Any multiple in there
it gives you a vector subspace. Only
positive multiples of vectors already in
there are again in there gives you a
cone. Well, this is a cone, too.
Anything in there, another thing in
there is in there, and positive
multiples are in there. Negative are
not.
These are cones, and these are cones.
These are even convex cones.
It's not such a big difference. It's
just not It's You could say relativity
is instead of having
cones that are half spaces, you have
cones that are proper cones, right?
Okay.
And of course, the whole idea is these
particles, if you think in velocities,
and I I
I wouldn't Usually, one would say
nothing runs faster than the speed of
light, but faster refers to speed,
right? And uh we haven't talked about
that quite yet, because we could measure
we could measure the length of the
velocity of the space-time velocity. We
could measure the length of this V. I
get a specific number, but that's not
the velocity an observer sees. It's just
the length in the of the space-time
velocity. If we talk about speed, we
mean what an observer sees in his
laboratory. We'll come to that, okay?
But the intuition is these guys can
never overtake these guys, right? Okay,
anyway, so that's the definitions.
Um but obviously, in order to talk about
notions we are more familiar with,
namely what an observer sees, we don't
know what observers are, right?
In order to do that,
we need to define observers.
Definition.
Is it?
That That's true. Thank you.
Definition. So, we we're now always
dealing with a space-time.
What's an observer?
An observer
is a
um world line,
a world line
gamma
with
gamma g v gamma v gamma
greater than zero. I do not always write
the gamma of lambda gamma of lambda,
okay? Greater than zero and g of t v
gamma greater than zero. So, you say,
"Ah, like a massive particle world
line." Indeed, observers in relativity
are always observers that could be
realized as massive objects, because
they have to carry with them a
measurement apparatus or something,
okay? An observer is a world line gamma
with these properties. Oh, and usually
one calls world lines like this, one
calls them time-like. I don't like that.
Time-like There's no time in the game so
far, okay? Let's get rid of this notion
time-like, space-like, light-like. Let's
not talk about it, because the like
already tells you it doesn't mean what
it says.
Okay? So, let's just not say it.
Okay.
Later on, you're allowed to do that.
It's like uh swear words. If you have
children, right?
You tell them, "Don't say that!
God damn it!"
Okay.
So, later on, you you may reinstate
that. So, an an observer is a world line
gamma with this together with So, it's
not only a world line
together
with
uh a choice
of basis
e0
depending on the parameter on the same
parameter lambda on which the curve
depends,
e1 of lambda, e2 of lambda, and e3 of
lambda. So, we're talking about
four-dimensional space-time. You can
easily make a D-dimensional space-time
out of this
of
each
T gamma of lambda m
where
the part where the observer
world line
passes.
Now, actually, the precise formulation
would be an observer
is a smooth
curve
in the frame bundle
LM
over M.
Okay?
Um because I want Okay, I draw a
picture. So,
this is a curve gamma in space-time.
Yes?
I mean, I think there's a
very important new point in it. Now, we
speak of
four-dimensional manifold.
Yes.
But in Newtonian picture, the time was a
function, and we were staying in a
three-dimensional manifold.
No, the Newtonian space-time was a
four-dimensional manifold. But because
the time was just defined as a smooth
function. On the four-dimensional
manifold.
And those direction or those level
surfaces of the lot
where the absolute time is five.
That's a three-dimensional
surface, and that is the space at time
five. So, the Newtonian space-time
manifold was four-dimensional.
Yes.
Pardon me?
No, but the choice of basis is the
observer. Let Let me come to it. Let me
come to it.
So, um
there's also something missing here if
writing something here. So, the idea is
the following. You have an a world line
that at every of its points lies within
the half cone
prescribed by space-time. Okay?
And now, you make here an additional
requirement if you require something of
this basis, but that still doesn't fix
it. If
the
A'th basis vector at the position lambda
and the B'th basis vector
taken in this inner product, if the
result is eta AB,
and eta AB is just
1 -1 -1 -1 is this collection of
numbers. The rest are zeros.
AB
So, one could say they're also normal.
Well, that would be more like a unit,
but also normal as a Lorentzian metric,
which means you
they produce this result.
That's a requirement on the choice of
basis.
And it means
Oh, no, I forgot something else. Okay?
And this E01 is the same as the tangent
to the curve.
Okay, so what does that mean? That means
that For instance, at this point
P here,
P is gamma of some lambda one, say.
There's a tangent vector
like this, and that one we would call E0
of lambda.
Of course, an element of the tangent
space. Okay?
Should write this in a little bit. Keep
it here.
Uh gamma of lambda one is the point P
where it's going through.
And then, so that's the For the first
basis element, I don't have a choice. I
choose the tangent vector. And for the
others, I choose
further ones.
And here, I only draw two more
of lambda one.
I only draw two more because my picture
is at most three-dimensional. Okay, so
you need to think of this in
perspective. And the idea is that they
pairwise give either zero No, pairwise
they give um
zero, but this with this itself gives a
one, of course, and the others give
minus ones.
That's how they're chosen. You can
always do that. Okay?
And um
at another point down here,
you have this. This one is fixed.
But then, you have two more, E1, E2.
They are not fixed because, intuitively
speaking, you could
choose any rotation thereof, right? But
you can no longer change the E0 because
that one is fixed.
Now, you see, an observer is a little
more than just a world line. Yes. Why
did you put an index on the lambda?
Mm.
Because I wanted to say
this uh in order to develop the picture
further.
So, this is uh
gamma of lambda two. Well, that's silly.
A lambda zero.
Lambda zero, lambda zero, lambda zero
because soon I'm going to talk about
these two.
I think the one on the top
Yeah, that's right.
I'm sorry. Thank you.
Yes?
If it's written like this, an an
arbitrary curve doesn't necessarily have
the tangent vector normalized one.
So, so
Yes.
So, is it Is it always normalized one by
definition? Yes, here we do that because
um that will help us later on. You can
always do that because you can
reparameterize a curve.
Uh and then, we'll have to do with the
definition of time that comes in a
second.
So, this is intentional. So, I could
have specialized here already
to one, which is greater than zero, and
that would be in accordance with this.
Thank you for the observation, but
that's exactly intended.
Okay?
Yes?
So, basically, our basis expects the
signature of our metric.
If we have
It must. It It couldn't do anything
else. You would never find a basis that
is dia- where this is diagonal and
doesn't have the signature.
It could be 5 -7 -3 and so on, but then
you could rescale the vectors again.
Yes, that's right. That's right.
So, that That's the condition.
What What's a frame bundle?
A frame bundle, yes. I said precise, and
and and that's something I didn't
explain. A frame bundle is where you
have a manifold, and at each point P,
you attach as a fiber, not the tangent
space, but the space where
in the fiber, a point in the fiber is a
choice of basis at the point P.
A choice of basis of the tangent space.
So, the fiber at a point no longer
contains all the tangent vectors.
It contains all
qua- uh quadruplets
of tangent vectors that constitute a
basis.
Okay? And then, if you have So, if these
are is are all possible basis here, and
then you have a curve in the
in the tangent bundle, a smooth curve,
that actually helps you encode that from
here to here,
so this doesn't all of a sudden change
to this, but this goes smoothly.
If you want to say this precisely, you
need to say it's a smooth curve in the
frame bundle.
Okay? But you can ignore that. The idea
suffices here. Yes. Um would it be
sufficient to say that the
uh basis vectors as function of lambda
should be differentiable?
Basis vectors as a function of lambda
should be differentiable.
Um
Well, the question is what precisely
that means because then you would um
need to have a a map from lambda to
where?
Because for each lambda, you go to a
different tangent space. So, maybe you
could say you have
four smooth curves in the tangent
bundle.
Four smooth curves in the tangent
bundle, yes. And then, you could um
additionally require that they are
always orthonormal in this sense. That
would probably be a a leaner way. Yes.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay, so you see, the physical
interpretations, an observer is more
than just a world line because an
observer will feel quite different,
observe quite different, whether he's
just, say, freely falling or whether
he's freely falling and rotating. And
how do you capture the rotating? Well,
you can only capture it via the attached
frame.
Okay? But an an arbitrary observer will
just do something like this, right? We
need to say which observer you have in
order to say, "Well, no, it doesn't do
this. It It goes like this." or
something like that. Okay? Okay, but
that's the abstract notion of an
observer.
And um
there come again two physical
postulates.
So, that's P3 because we already had
two. P3
is
a clock
carried
by a specific observer
And we'll call an observer always gamma
E, where the E stands for this
whole selection, right?
A clock carried by a specific observer
will show
would measure
will measure
a time
interval.
Well, will measure a time
tau
is time tau
integral from lambda one to lambda from
zero to lambda one.
The ones I chose.
D lambda
square root
of G gamma of lambda V gamma gamma of
lambda
V gamma gamma of lambda.
Between
the two
events. So, that's uh relativist's
jargon. An event is a point in
space-time. Between the two events,
gamma of lambda zero, and that event is
start the clock.
Or rather, push the start button of the
clock because um um
pushing is
something localized in space, pushing a
button, and in time. Okay, that's an
event. Start the clock and gamma of
lambda one stop the clock.
So, if this observer decides
to activate his stopwatch
that he carries with him
and he switches it on here.
He lets it run and he switches it off
there.
Then the length of this world line
in space-time as measured by the metric,
which this is nothing but the length
functional, right?
The length of the world line
in space-time has a meaning.
It has the meaning of the time that the
clock measures.
Now, this seems a rather arbitrary
postulate. In fact, one can This is one
of the nicest things that you can look
at with a light clock. Maybe I explain
that later.
Um
So, this is very solid
and this defines what time this observer
sees. And please note, so far in the
discussion of relativistic space-time,
this is the first instance
the first instance that the word time
enters the discussion.
You agree?
I didn't talk about time.
Which means time is a derived notion
in this context.
I don't talk about time such
just like that.
I talk about time as the time that a
clock measures.
Okay? Now, you could ask construct such
a clock and prove it. You can.
You can construct a light clock. I I
maybe come to that.
However,
time of an observer as a clock measures
and the clock is a clock that's carried
by this observer. So, this yellow path
in space-time, this yellow part of the
world line, is the history of the clock.
There is nothing in this definition that
suggests that another clock
taking another path
even from the same point starting point
to the same end point, but along another
path as long as it's a path that is also
an observer
will show the same time. Is there any
reason to assume? No, not a priori.
Well, in fact, it will not be the case.
Time will depend on the world line that
the clock takes in space-time according
to this definition.
Okay? That's all. So, if people say
the the concept of time is changed in
relativity, that's that's right because
there is no longer one absolute time.
You cannot look at a point in space-time
like in Newtonian space-time. Do you
remember in Newtonian space-time
so compare
in Newtonian
space-time
I could just pick a point
P, a single point without observer,
without a second point, without starting
clock and stopping a clock. I could pick
a point
and I would know the time associated
with that point.
I would simply know it.
Well, you can say, "Yeah, but you could
rescale this absolute time." Yes, that
you could do, but nevertheless, once you
have settled the absolute time
an event comes at a certain time.
And other events come at the same time
of the absolute time function and then
you can ask, "What's an event at the
same time?"
And if you have two events like our
picture up here
this is just yet a derived notion
because you say, "Okay, this point P and
this point Q, the difference in time
independent of how you go from here to
here and independent of what path your
clock takes, it's always T of P minus T
of Q." Okay?
That's the Newtonian concept of time.
Here, this is entirely different,
totally different. There is no time
associated to an individual event.
There's not even a time difference
associated to two different events.
There's a time difference associated to
a certain path that the clock takes
between two events and that clock is
started here and stopped here and then
it will show this time.
Yes. So far,
have you been talking about the real
world or chart or how do you know that
it's chart independent? This is all the
real world and you can see here
because I don't use any components.
This is the metric.
This is the velocity. This has nothing
to do with components.
I haven't written down a single
component so far.
And also the little cones here, they're
objective.
Because
say this is here and now where I am.
This point, okay?
And now I lit
a light a little light bulb for just a
millisecond.
It blinks.
And then it will take some time until
the light has reached
uh some member of the audience over here
and some member of the audience over
there, but will go out in a
spherical way, right? This impulse, this
light flash.
And um well, depending on your frame of
references on very roughly speaking
this is what goes out, but remember this
is in tangent space, okay? So, the the
light
ray will actually go out more like
say like this
and the other one maybe like that if you
have a very vicious space-time.
Uh where the cones start
if the cones develop more like this, not
develop if they if they are positioned
like this.
Right? So, the actual light
goes along along a null trajectory and
this is just the tangent at that point.
So, if I draw these guys actually wrong,
I should rather draw
these guys, but then it all again
depends on what frame of reference
you're in, how these are tilted. But
anyway, so
I can make the experiment. I send a
photon in this direction and that
direction and the photon does what the
photon does, right?
And that is the velocity of the photon
here and the velocity of the photon
there is like the velocity of the bird,
right?
It's unimpressed by choice of chart. The
position of the cone is totally
unimpressed by the position of by the
choice of chart because it's an
objective reality that at that point a
photon sent in that direction will have
that velocity. But the cone is a
picture.
Oh, I see. Did you ask this question in
in the email?
With the the real world, yes. Okay. So,
there was this question, which is a
justified question. I always talk about
the manifold and all these objects as
the real world and then as the charts is
kind of what we make of it.
Now, of course, you could say, "Well,
it's not the real world. It's it's a
manifold, right?" This is also an idea.
But the point is
if we think about the real world as
physicists, we think. That's what we do,
right? We have no
further access to the real world but to
make concepts and then to
make experiments that relate these
concepts. So, if I think, "Oh, there's a
bird and it has a velocity." That's
already thinking because you can't see
the velocity in the world. The velocity
already is a concept, right? But this
object has a velocity, but our idea of
velocity is not chart dependent. It's
only that in high school you're
indoctrinated that all of a sudden you
have to associate velocities with three
numbers.
Right? That's what they teach in school.
But the concept of velocity that a child
has has nothing to do with these three
numbers.
Right? So, the
what you learn in school is already in a
chart, but the concept of velocity is
there independent of a chart. Okay? And
that is when I say that's in the real
world. That's our concept about the real
world.
Okay?
Good. Okay.
So, in this sense, this is in the real
world, okay? And this is all a picture
in the real world and none of this
formulation depends on on a chart.
Okay.
Now, there's a certain amount of
terminology that goes with all of that.
Um
you would call this tau
the proper time.
The proper time.
Or the eigen
time
of this
observer from here to here.
But you call it proper time in order to
distinguish it from the Newtonian time.
Right? But in this theory, it's just
time. Time is what a clock measures.
Okay?
So, that's um the first thing. And let's
let's make an example on application for
that.
Application or  example.
The example is take a space time
R4
with the standard topology and some
smooth atlas for it.
And take as G
um the G that's given by G I J in a
chart X
equals eta I J.
Okay? And so we have an atlas that
contains
R4 times the identity on R4
as a chart.
And if that exists and you have this,
you can calculate the Christoffel
symbols. Therefore, it follows gamma I J
K in that chart are zero everywhere.
And the chart covers the whole manifold.
That means this space time
an oriented atlas, if you wish, the
space time
Okay, and you choose a time orientation.
Time orientation in the same chart
I is chosen as 1 0 0 0 I for instance.
Okay?
Uh you have this time orientation. And
of course, from the G, you can make a
connection.
But because this is zero everywhere, the
Riemann curvature will vanish.
That means this space time
is flat.
And we have chosen a chart in which it
looks particularly nice. Aha, this
situation is called special relativity.
This situation is called special
relativity.
Or one should say it's the domain of
special relativity. You have a flat
space time.
But otherwise, special relativity is not
different from general relativity. Not
at all.
Okay?
And um
Now you may consider
um
two observers.
And I give all of this in in this chart
because I need to write it down.
So, one observer
is called gamma.
And uh
his um
world line
in this chart
has components
that are lambda 0 0 0.
And run from 0 to 1. So, if I am in the
chart, let's say it looks like this.
Okay?
Good. And you see you take the
derivative, you get 1 0 0 0. That has
certainly positive inner product with
the T here.
With because we have signature plus
minus minus minus, so this is an is an
observer.
Then we have a second observer delta
0 1 to M
who takes a rather more adventurous
route.
Um
delta X
is the Ith component. Delta X the Ith
component is
lambda.
No, it comes in two sections.
Lambda
alpha times lambda and alpha from 0
to 1
um
excluded both.
0 0
I if lambda is less or equal to 1/2. Now
we run up to parameter value 1.
And here I get lambda I 1
minus alpha lambda
0 0 Ith component.
Lambda
greater than
1/2.
And that should be, depending on the
alpha,
that should look
like this.
Okay? If the alpha
is uh
going close to
to 1
then
So, look down here, you have a cone
that is like this.
At every point you have a cone. In this
chart I've chosen
the cones everywhere stand upright.
Okay?
That's uh
essentially the choice that I have this
eta here in this chart. In this chart in
another chart, the same metric may look
different, but that's why I choose this
chart. Okay? So, this the situation. And
if the alpha goes to 1,
this one is going closer and closer and
closer and closer to the boundary of the
cone, but it doesn't hit the boundary of
the cone, of course. It can't. Okay, if
I let the alpha go to 1 or higher, then
I no longer have an observer delta.
So, I have to do something like this.
Okay. So, you of course see where this
is going. It's going to the twin paradox
on, right? There are two twins. They're
they're they're both born. One
just falls freely in space.
And the other one also falls freely in
space in another direction because the
mother kicked him in that direction.
We're in space as thought experiment,
right? And then at some point he's being
kicked back and then and then he meets
the other twin again. Okay? You could
also think of rockets and flying away
and all kinds of stories. Okay?
And um
So, the point is we have to calculate
what is the time elapsing of the clock
that this guy gets for his birthday. And
what's the time elapsing on the clock
that the twin that was first kicked away
um shows on his clock. Okay?
Um let's calculate.
Okay. So,
tau for the gamma guy. Okay? Tau gamma.
Tau gamma gamma delta.
How does this go?
Is integral. We go over the parameters
from start to end, the 0 to 1 in this
case.
We have to integrate over the square
root of the G of the velocity. I
immediately write it in this chart. G I
J, the velocity is gamma in the chart
Ith component dot gamma in this chart
J's component dot. Do you agree?
That's what it is.
Okay, let's quickly evaluate it 0 to 1 d
lambda.
d lambda
Um G I J is this eta.
Okay?
And the gamma dot
is 1 0 0 0.
So, the only term that survives is the
one here. 1 * 1 * 1 + 0 0 0. So, there's
1.
Equals
Integral from 0 to 1 over 1 is 1.
So, yes? I think that should be 1 minus
lambda in the in the delta.
Here? Yeah,
and the alpha outside the
What did I do in my notes? Probably
you're right. You had time to think
about this. No, I had it like this.
Okay? So, um
So, let's see. Okay, so I I I want to I
want to go there and I um
I arrived here after time
lambda half. I arrived at
I want to be at
alpha times
lambda.
Okay?
And then I want to go back.
So, I have arrived at alpha half because
the time has half. Then I want to go
back minus alpha
lambda.
Confused.
Are you sure?
1 minus lambda and the alpha goes out.
Is that right?
So, let's see. At 0, this is alpha.
That's not good.
Oh, that's right. Okay, so at la Yeah,
but lambda be Okay, so that means at
lambda 1/2
I I you're right. Okay. Sorry. At lambda
1/2, this is 1/2 alpha.
That's right. And at lambda equals 1,
this is zero again. I think you're
right. Thank you. Thank you. Yes? Is
there any subtlety because the observer
does not have a smooth curve or it's for
the purpose of this it's it's No, this
is
because you're evaluating an integral,
you can evaluate it piecewise.
The curve
and so you can take out this point and
you can make it smooth and works the
same. It's just this is the easiest to
to to integrate, but the the principle
is always the same. Okay, that's right.
Okay, so here you have 1. So, for this
guy
uh 1 year passes. 1.
I'm sorry.
Now, the other observer
has integral 0 to 1/2
d lambda of this expression. So, we have
to evaluate this first in this first
part, this is 1 alpha 0 0. This gives
you a 1 squared minus alpha squared.
Right?
Uh then you do the second half, 1/2 to 1
square root.
Um
1 squared
minus
Ah. Uh now we derive with respect to
lambda, then only this term survives.
That's um
uh uh minus alpha. So, it's minus minus
alpha squared.
Correct?
1 with the respect to alpha only this is
the minus alpha. Yeah, I think that's
correct. This is of course twice the
same term. Okay, not surprising from
from the picture, but uh
we're better safe than sorry here. So,
this is uh from uh 0 to 1
uh square root of 1 minus alpha squared
d lambda, uh which is square root 1
minus alpha squared.
And you see if alpha is not zero, which
we excluded because then it's the same
guy,
the time that this guy travels is
reduced.
It's only the square root of 1 minus
alpha squared. And the closer the alpha
goes to 1, the more this guy
we would uh almost tend to say
approaches the speed of light. I haven't
shown that yet, but the more he goes to
the boundary of the cone, the more you
can
drive this time to zero.
So, if you only move away fast enough
and come away come back fast enough,
you don't age much
according to the clock that's being
carried.
Okay?
Now, this is of course the twin paradox
on, and the paradox on is supposed to
consist in the fact that what about
relativity, right? But who talked about
any relativity? This is the definition
of time shown by a clock.
But maybe at this point one gets very
suspicious of the whole framework
because one says, "I mean, how can that
be?"
And um indeed, if we take it seriously,
so taking
the clock postulate
P1
C uh P3
seriously,
one better
come up
with a realistic
clock design
that supports
the postulate.
You can say, "Well, you can tell me a
lot about what a clock measures. What
does a clock measure?"
And um the idea, but we're not going to
do this in detail, partly because I
haven't introduced all the terminology
yet, but it's quite useful to see the
following. So, assume I have a little I
have two little mirrors.
And
I let a photon run from here to here. It
gets reflected, goes back, and so on. It
goes back and forth.
If I draw the history of that, it looks
like this in space time.
There's the cone at every point.
The mirror runs inside the cone, but
light runs on the boundary.
Now, here there's another cone.
The other mirror runs inside the cone,
but right light runs on the boundary.
Okay? Let's say like this.
And of course, it's a clock because it
makes tick
tock.
Okay?
It's a clock.
Now,
very roughly speaking, if you bring
these two
mirrors closer together, doesn't make
tick tock, it makes tick tock tick tock
tick tock tick tock tick tock. You can
be arbitrarily precise. It's a fantastic
clock, it's a light clock. It's a
fantastic because it works
relativistically.
Light is a relativistic matter theory,
we'll come to that. And um so, the
working is relativistic. Now,
you take another clock
and let it run like this.
So, now lots could be argued about what
the real distance of these guys is and
so on. This is a very rough estimate, so
I'm not talking about here and I'm not
talking about here, but if I make them
very small, it's not so bad.
And now, let's count the ticks here.
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
12 ticks.
Now, I do the same here.
Let's say I start somewhere here.
5 6
8 8
There you go.
It's shorter.
It's a light clock.
Okay? Yes.
Yes. Yes. So, one has to talk about if
this guy moves away, what the distance
of these mirrors is in the system of in
the moving system. Yes. Um
I said we I haven't introduced all the
terminology to do this make this
precise, but at this point I think the
picture is rather helpful than only
letting this abstract result here. Okay?
Yes. In the example before, did we make
use of the
chosen basis
of the observer?
No.
No. You mean that the chart?
You mean the chart here or that we've
chosen? I'm just asking if we if we
needed the chosen basis of the observer
or not.
Well, I mean, if if I want to write down
precisely
how the line should run, I prefer to go
to a chart and I write down the numbers,
okay? But um
the objects I calculate are independent
of that. I think he means the frame
bundle.
The frame bundle?
Sorry, no. Please ask again.
I mean that we defined the observer as
the
of a curve And and the frame. Yeah, we
didn't use that frame yet. We didn't use
the frame yet. So, the clock is only the
length along the world line, independent
of how quickly the frame rotates or not
rotates in quotation marks. We'll
get the notion of that. Okay, yes.
Each twin will see the other one move
away, right? So, Yes.
Why does one age more than the other?
Well, because of the clock postulate.
Okay, that was a mean answer. So, the
point is you're trying to construct a
paradox, right?
And the point is
Well, first of all, this guy has
inertial motion and this one hasn't. So,
this one will realize at some point he
has to be accelerated again, okay? So,
that already So, you give both of them
an iPhone and at some point the the
screen of the iPhone will change for
this guy if he holds it like this,
right? Okay. Um
However,
that is an ex That's not the explanation
for the effect. That's just the
explanation why they are different,
okay? Um
sometimes
it's claimed that all the effect is here
in the acceleration period.
Well, this is
real nonsense because for many reasons
this is nonsense. It's just the the
total length here that counts, and then
imagine I had done the following.
Imagine I had asked the question,
there's a twin
going from here to here, and there's
another twin doing this.
Who has aged more?
That's a totally ill-defined question
because they have to reunite to compare
their clocks.
If not, then it depends on the state or
let's say I do it even like this. Uh la
la la. Say like this.
Who has I mean, the other thing is also
ill-defined. If this guy here in this
flat space time, okay, this is already
pretty bad. Um like this. Uh
so, this one will see all these points
here in the flat space time, all these
directions as equal to his time.
And this one will see all these as the
points of equal time to him.
So, this one will say,
"Now that I'm this old, how old is he?"
But this one will say, "Now I'm this
old, how old is he?"
Okay? So, you need So, the point is you
can't do that. You you need to
to reunite in order to compare.
So, therefore, a statement like the
whole effect appears here, I wonder from
whose point of view.
Right? You can't do that. You have to
synchronize clocks and to compare them
again at the same point. Why? Because if
you're not at the same point, you don't
even know when to compare them.
Okay?
That's yes.
What could happen if they could somehow
see each other during the movement?
Okay.
Okay, I think we're Okay, all
interesting questions, okay? Uh the
point I think we're we're we're we're
getting too far from from what I wanted
to to to tell you. Um No, no, no, it's
not an excuse. I mean, of course, we
could start discussing this and so on,
but every discussion now would heavily
rely on this being a flat space-time
because there I can really What I did
here, I can say these are the points of
equal time. In the curved space, that's
not even so clear
what that is. Okay? So, there are
forms of what's the distance, radar
distance or not. In curved space-time,
this becomes all It's I don't want to
confuse you with flat space concepts
which we could now employ uh to make
progress here. Okay? That That's the
point. So, I I think I leave it with
these remarks at this point. And um I
have another important definition.
Or another important postulate.
Postulate.
Let gamma E
be an observer.
And delta
be a massive
particle
worldline.
Massive particle worldline
that
is parameterized
such that
G of V delta
V delta
is one everywhere. Why do I do this?
Well,
I parameterize worldlines according to
the time that a clock would show that
travels with the particle.
Why do I do this? Well, because then I
save a lot of normalizing factors in the
following definitions. And I can always
re-parameterize a worldline. So, I
choose to parameterize a worldline by
the time a clock carried by that
particle would show.
Why not? So, I do that.
Then
the observer
Aha. Now, let's make another further
assumption. Assume
or suppose
Suppose the observer
and the particle
meet
somewhere
in space-time.
Do we assume that the observer worldline
is also parameterized?
Uh is
Yes, that's already in the definition.
That's because of the normalization of
the of the frame.
Yes.
Meets uh Well, somewhere in space-time
uh meet also in Newtonian space-time is
a space-time concept.
Right? I was here, you were here, but we
weren't here at the same time. So,
meeting is a space-time concept. Meet
That means that
there is a parameter lambda one for the
observer and a parameter lambda two, or
let's call them tau one and tau two
for the particle where they both meet at
the same point. So, you have an observer
that is goes about happy observing here.
Okay?
And a
a really fat, very massive particle
happens to be where the observer is at a
certain instant.
Now, this particle has a velocity in
space-time
V
delta. Agree?
This is the delta and this is the gamma.
That's a space-time velocity, sometimes
called a four-velocity
cuz it's a
velocity to the worldline.
Okay? But that's not the velocity we're
talking about in real life cuz we're
talking about three velocities. Now, the
observer
this observer
sees or measures
measures
the
three-velocity
or spatial velocity
This observer measures the
three-velocity or spatial velocity
of this
particle
as
Well, the velocity is maybe Well,
a little V.
It's not the curly V, the space-time V,
it's a little V.
is
G
of
V
delta delta of lambda.
Well, that's at the point where they
coincide. Delta tau two.
comma
Ah, no. No, no G. Sorry.
No G.
It's um
epsilon
alpha
of
the velocity V delta delta of tau
two.
E alpha
where alpha now only runs from one to
three.
And independent of what that is,
this is an expansion
in
only these two.
One color.
In only these two
basis vectors of our observer. Do you
see that? E1 E2, and the E0 is not part
of this expansion.
So, the resulting vector
will lie in this
tangent space.
Okay? Somewhere there.
But what are the components with respect
to E1, E2, and E3? Well, they're the
components selected with an epsilon.
And I need to tell you what the epsilon
is.
And that's subtle.
Where
epsilon zero
epsilon one, epsilon two, epsilon three
is the unique
dual basis
of
E0, E1, E2, E3.
Aha. So, the observer at each point has
a basis of four vectors.
To this four basis, there is a unique
dual basis.
Of this unique dual basis, we're then
only going to use
these three guys and then again these
three guys in writing down this
three-velocity.
Now,
sometimes one thinks, well, then epsilon
one, two, three is the unique dual basis
to E1, E2, E3. No, because these are
vectors in four-dimensional space. Four
vectors in a four-dimensional space are
not a basis and there's no unique dual
basis. I need to find the full dual
basis and then I pick only these three.
You say, what a terribly ill-defined
concept, right? I mean, for another
observer, it would look different.
Oh, yes, it will.
And that's the whole point. Because this
observer will see this velocity. I don't
know whether I should attempt to draw
this, but this observer will see this
velocity in this
in this space span of this E1, E2, E3,
and will probably see it somehow like
this.
This is the V delta where this is the
curly V delta
at this point.
Delta of tau two.
You see? And that is the velocity we
speak of in the lab.
And now, if you know this velocity we
speak of in the lab, you can ask, is it
smaller or faster than the speed of
light?
And so on. Or what is the velocity of
light? Yes? Um do we just define the
three-velocity to be this, or can we
somehow connect this to the
velocity one classically
has a notion of?
Well, the point is, from the way we came
by defining the concepts top-down,
this is a derived concept.
Because what is now objective in
relativity in space-time, this velocity,
the yellow velocity, is objective
because the worldline is objective. It's
in the real world. This is a tangent
vector in the real world.
Right?
But this velocity, the three-velocity,
we had to construct with the use of an
observer who sees this three-velocity.
Another observer
with another frame
will extract from the same objective
four-velocity
another three-velocity.
Okay?
That's it. That's the whole secret to
different observers seeing different
things. And And it's even not very
different from classical mechanics
because also there different observers
see different velocities. It's only here
that because of the cone and the
different observers, they can never see
a massive particle velocity uh
Well, I would say faster or bigger than
the speed of light, but we haven't
talked about yet how the metric looks
like here, but of course we can do that.
Right? So, you can say that the spatial
metric that the observer uses in this
tangent space, not in an extended
sub-manifold, but in the tangent space
is of course -1 -1 -1 because it's just
the part of g e alpha e beta.
Right?
So, then if you put a minus sign before
it, it looks a bit a little bit more
friendly. Okay? So, you can then take
this vector and measure it with this
metric, and then you get a length of
this vector, and this length will never
exceed one.
Right? So, the spatial length of the
spatial vector won't exceed one.
And that is what it says, it's slower
than there's an upper limit to
velocities you can see. Spatial
velocities.
But in the space-time has to do with
lying inside the cone.
And again, here it is important. Now,
it's not the charts, well, the observers
are a kind of chart because it's a very
localized chart, only at one point. It's
a it's a frame in the tangent space,
right? Could maybe extend this to a
chart in the manifold, but that's not
even interesting. It's only at this one
point these different directions, but
again it's important. This is objective,
and this concept is derived from an
objective concept, namely the tangent,
the velocity of the curve of the world
line.
This velocity is a derived concept with
respect to an observer.
Okay? And um
so, in this velocity also, if you now
want to ask how far does this guy run in
a millisecond, you can't go very far
because then space-time will change and
so on. Um you take the time of this
observer and his measure in space of
this observer and so on, and you
calculate this.
Okay? And that is then just a notion of
velocity like we know it in this
observer's frame. But this is all
observer-dependent.
The objective thing is the world line
and its tangent. And the rest is just
extraction of information.
Right? So, one of the
issues is getting rid of this notion
that you somehow start objectively in
three-space, and then you construct the
four notions out of it. It's the wrong
way around. You first have the notions
in space-time, they're objective,
and then you construct the
observer-dependent notions as derived
objects. Yes. We defined the small v
only as the absolute value of this
little arrow you drew.
No, no, no, no. The small v is um a
vector.
It's an expansion
in the spaces e1, e2, e3. Uh it's not
covector, it's a vector. It is. This is
a covector, the alpha's covector, alpha
running from 1 to 3,
acting on this four-vector, and then
being
dotted into here.
It is a vector. So, this is a vector.
It's even a vector in space-time. This v
is a space-time vector. It just happens
to lie in the span of e1, e2, e3.
Yes?
That's exactly what I intended to do.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yes? By calling this world line
objective, isn't it a little bit weird
because it's an
objective it's in the real world, and
but it would look if
uh it could look differently if um other
people in the real world look at this
No, no.
But
No, it wouldn't. No, it wouldn't.
A bird flies by.
The bird does what the bird does. And
that's that's what what the world line,
the history of the bird is the history
of the bird. You may picture the history
of the bird in different charts, but
that's not what's happening.
Okay, you may be confused by the fact
that I draw a picture, and you can say
drawing the picture is already
implicitly using a chart or something
like this.
Okay, so it's a metaphor.
That's why I don't like these pictures.
So, so it's a metaphor, right?
All these pictures are metaphors, right?
Imagine Think of
the history
of this particle. And that's a curve, an
objective curve in space-time. That's
the idea. It has an objective velocity
and so on. But then come different
observers and measure it, and after all
this is a postulate how the observer
sees that.
Okay?
I'm
somewhat surprised that this is a
postulate after defining eigen time.
Yes.
I could have
if you have eigen time, and you have the
um curvature, I'm sorry, the the measure
in here,
it seems like it's a funny postulate,
but in fact I need would need what I
would need is for an observer at a
point, I would need all points which
from the point of view of this observer
are at the same time, then I could
consider curves through here, and I
could start defining these velocities.
But the point is as I define observer,
it just consists of these tangent
vectors to this and that direction, and
it tells me nothing about what happens
in the manifold a little bit away.
And in fact, in curved space-time, this
is really an issue also of of
definition, what you actually mean how
far somebody is away. You could define a
radar time and stuff like this. Now, I
mean, imagine for instance in curved
space-time or any in any space-time, you
have an observer, and you have another
observer.
Say even they they they they go like
that.
And now, but it's a curved space-time.
So, now you say how far is this guy away
from me? Now, this is uh the Earth, and
this is a star. Now, what you can do,
you can send light, but light will
maybe run like this depending on how the
cones change, okay? And then the light
will be reflected and will come back.
And then you can use this radar time as
it's called, the time from here to here,
you maybe divide it by two or or
something, you can use this as a measure
of distance, half this time. Okay? But
now imagine some vicious
entity in the universe removed this
point from the space-time.
For instance, by or or put a black hole
there or something, right?
So, then nothing of the sort will
happen.
And then the result will be this light
ray never comes back.
How far is the other guy away?
Infinitely far away?
You see,
these ideas of distance and and stuff,
this becomes very I mean, it becomes a
matter of definition, and you need to
think very, very carefully what you
actually mean there. So, therefore,
defining the spatial velocity
in the sense like, well, let's first
define here space, and then let's look
at curves again and so on, and then use
the time, it's not a bad idea, and
locally it will probably work and blah
blah blah, but this is much cleaner
because where I am, I know that I am
there, then the tangent space is there,
I have the frame and so on.
Okay? That's the idea.
Yes?
I mean, this of course this is assumed
that you're in the real the same point,
but I mean, in real life the there's
always I mean, the clock is you know,
it's there, right? And I'm not at the
same point. Could it could it be that
the space is so curved that even if you
have a clock there, it doesn't actually
you cannot perform this thing
experimentally
or Well, if curvature gets very high, it
gets more and more difficult. We'll come
to that.
Okay. Okay. Okay, so so I need to stop
your questions because I have uh
two more things to say.
Um
Um another consequence
is the following.
Um an observer
gamma e
will
extract
um
quantities
measurable
in
his
laboratory
from
objective
space-time quantities
always
like that.
So, the prime example for this is take
the F tensor, the Faraday tensor,
the Faraday 02 tensor
of electromagnetism.
So, in a chart, you have all seen this.
F A B
is this guy that has zeros here, it's
anti-symmetric, has e1, e2, e3 here,
-e1, -e2, -e3 here,
and then has the B um 1 2
3 1
3 minus
ooh
uh two
um
two three
one B1 and then here minus B3 B2 minus
B1 something like this, okay?
You've seen this, right? The tensor that
combines the E and the B field.
Well, this is already in a frame.
So, this is already
the F
E A E B
of a particular observer.
No wonder that different observers see
different E and B fields because this is
this, okay?
And then of course you can come up with
funny ideas like you only look at the E0
um E
alpha component and you call that E
alpha.
And you only look at the E alpha E beta
component
and um
take then an epsilon alpha beta gamma
and you call that B gamma.
That's essentially this extraction and
the other way around. Okay?
But this is highly observer dependent.
Highly.
And here in the epsilon you see some of
the funny behavior of the B fields.
Okay?
So, the objective space-time quantity is
the Faraday 02 tensor
which is unimpressed by charts or
observers looking at it. It is what it
is. It is what Maxwell the Maxwell
equations say it is.
But then if you want to go to the lab
and measure it, you measure these
quantities because your lab is an
observer.
Your lab may be rotating for instance.
Then you measure different E and B
fields.
Okay?
So, the observer
is the
intertwiner between the objective
quantity in the real world described by
abstract tensors
and the quantities you measure in the
lab with respect to your observer frame.
That's it.
It's perfectly simple. This fully
explains the transformation law of the E
and the B if you change observer.
That's it.
One more blackboard, please.
Only a short question.
Yes.
Only epsilon here is again the um the
famous
1 2 3 is plus one and totally
anti-symmetric.
One has got to be careful. This is a 02
tensor.
This is a vector and this is a vector
for each alpha.
So, each of these is just a function.
It appears.
But um it's a space-time function.
But something that's a space-time tensor
in general may be a hypersurface
density.
Think about this.
Be careful.
As soon as you start relating things to
three spaces, they might change their
density weight. We talked about
densities before.
This just for the interpretation.
Okay.
So, uh final is now number four. I don't
know.
Role of the Lorentz transformations.
Now it's three.
So, the Lorentz transformations
Lorentz transformations
emerge
as follows.
Let
gamma E
and
gamma twiddle E twiddle
be observers
with
gamma uh of some lambda or some tau one
equals the gamma twiddle of some tau
two. Meaning the two observers which at
some point of the history
meet at the same point.
Very important.
Now one of them
has this frame
say
E0 E1 E2
and the other one has this frame
E0
twiddle E1 twiddle
E2 twiddle. That's roughly how that will
look like.
Okay. Let's have these two guys.
Now
we know
Well, let's for simplicity say uh
their times are chosen such that this is
the same time because otherwise I need
to have so many of these guys. Now it is
clear
that E0
to E1 all taken at time zero
uh all taken at tau equals zero
is a ba- and
E0 twiddle to E1 twiddle also taken at
tau equals zero are both
bases
for the same
for the same T gamma of zero
M.
Namely, these two are both bases for the
tangent space at this point.
That's the definition more or less.
That's totally clear.
Thus
if they're both bases, I can express
the twiddle bases in terms of the
untwiddle bases. Is that right? I can
change bases by a transformation which I
may call lambda.
Okay? And this lambda as a matrix
is in GL4.
It's a general linear map, an invertible
map. Otherwise I can't send a basis to a
basis.
That's what I know.
Now, what do we know? We know that G of
E A twiddle E B twiddle is eta AB. Why?
Because of the observer definition.
But now I can plug in. This is G of
Okay, now I can write it in components
GAB
E
Aha.
Uh
confusing?
Ah, yes, yes, yes. Uh I can write it as
Oh, hang on a second.
No, I don't even want to to write this
in components. This is now lambda B
lambda M A E M lambda N B E N.
But because this is C infinity linear,
well, anyway linear, I have lambda M A
lambda N
B G E M E N.
But this again by this also being
observed an observer is eta MN.
So, I have the condition eta AB equals
lambda lambda eta.
Uh that is these lambdas are element of
what we usually call the Lorentz
transformations.
Right?
So, that means what is the role of the
Lorentz transformation? The role of the
Lorentz transformation, so result
Lorentz
transformations
relate
the frames
the first thing, the frames of any two
observers
at the same point.
It's perfectly meaningless to talk about
the frame of this observer and the frame
of that observer and to say this comes
from this by Lorentz transformation.
They live in different tangent spaces.
Perfectly meaningless.
Lorentz transformations the frame relate
the frames of two observers. They do not
It doesn't make any sense in the first
place. They do not act on space-time.
They act on one tangent space of
space-time and relate observers who meet
there.
Or they act on another tangent space of
space-time and they act on observer
frames who meet there.
This has nothing to do with acting on
space-time points. So, the um
lambda mu nu X mu is the new space-time
point X twiddle mu
stuff
is I they all say utter nonsense.
Right?
This just isn't done. Now, you can do
this on flat space-time
and say all transformations I want to
look at are those
then you greatly restrict to linear
transformations which means you never
have to look at gammas if the original
space time was flat and you chose the
right chart but it also restricts you to
not being able to go to polar
coordinates and what has that to do with
relativity?
Absolutely nothing, right? So Lorentz
transformations on space time are a
terrible conceptual idea.
Just don't do that. They have no place
there.
Right? And then one does that, right? In
special relativity and then one says,
"Oh, in general relativity now allows
that these are not only Lorentz
transformations but any transformation."
Well, it was already allowed in special
relativity.
But if that was so they Sometimes people
say the Lorentz group is replaced by the
diffeomorphism group if you go to
general relativity. You now can go to
any frame where as before you couldn't.
Well, you could as you could but this
was nonsense and even if you say general
relativity is where you leave the
Lorentz transformations you go to others
where the Lorentz transformations keep
their value
where they had their value before.
So the Lorentz transformations in
special relativity have the same
meaning. Well, this is not their
meaning. This is nonsense. In special
This is also true in special relativity
if the space time is flat this still
holds.
So both in special and in general
relativity Lorentz transformations
relate observer frames at the same
point.
And on the whole space time be flat or
curved, it doesn't matter.
General diffeomorphisms can be
chosen in order to go to different
charts.
There is no difference.
Hence it's sometimes so dangerous to
start with special relativity in
concepts of Minkowski vector space as
the space of events because it clouds
your thinking.
Okay?
This is just an abuse of flat space
structure.
Thank you very much.